All right. For our last big review question,
Let's delve into Optimization, making programs faster.
Remember that we can only apply an optimization--
that is, we can only replace one subtree of a program with another--
if we don't change the semantics, the meaning, the answer of the program.
Here's another way to look at the challenge of optimization.
What we really want to know for optimization is given two functions, F and G,
do they both compute the same answer for all inputs.
This may seem a little abstract, but let me firm it up with a concrete example.
It might be that F is the original program, and G is the candidate optimized program.
If they compute the same answer on all inputs a,
then we can replace F with G wherever it occurs.
We can imagine framing this as some hypothetical procedure--optimization okay.
You just pass it in F and G and if F(a) = G(a) for all a, then you return True.
Otherwise you return False.
Now, this is clearly sketchy code. We sometimes call this psuedocode,
because it wouldn't actually work in Python, but you can imagine what would go there.
Somehow we're going to try this out--maybe we'll look at their source code.
We apply these rules that we did previously.
Maybe we test it out on a bunch of inputs.
Somehow we come to the conclusion that F(a) is always equal to G(a).
If so, we return True, and the optimization is okay.
Otherwise, the optimization is not safe, so we don't apply it.
Just to give one more concrete example, we expect optimization okay of F and G
to return True, but optimization okay of X and Y down here where X is a/a and Y is 1.
This should return False because remember if a equals 0 then this one is division by 0 exception,
and this one is 1, and those aren't the same thing.
All right. So here is the actual quiz.
I've written four statements, four claims, that refer to that optimization okay phrasing
or procedure from before.
It's kind of like a specification.
Here they are. We can implement optimization okay so that it returns a safe answer
for optimization in all cases, for all possible programs.
We cannot implement optimization okay that works precisely in all cases.
It is undecidable like the Halting Problem.
We cannot implement an optimization okay that works precisely for any case.
Then down here optimization of george f will and betty frieden implies
optimization okay of betty frieden and george f will. Check all that are true.